[Music]
dwayne johnson and his daughter Jasmine
are simply too cute to handle who's the
best daddy in the world he may be named
this year's sexiest man alive but the
rock is proving to be daddy gold on
Friday the actor instagrammed a sweet
video singing to his baby girl in honor
of her first birthday and her reaction
is priceless happy birthday to you she's
already clapping happy birthday dear
Jasmine happy birthday to you yay The
Fast & Furious 8 star captioned the
adorable father-daughter moment teaching
them young to start applauding the
moment daddy starts singing smart girl
happy first birthday baby girl got you
for life jasmine is Dwayne's first child
with girlfriend Lauren hash Ian and the
proud dad is constantly going all-out
for his little girl even dressing up as
her favorite Pokemon character for
Halloween oh you know what daddy's gonna
wear Pikachu caucus you understand I'm
sweating my ass off inside that cot but
you're dying right hot
what daddies do
[Music]
you